hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar drug development with
nuclear receptor knockout and humanized
rat models presented by andrew brown
product manager as well as kevin forbes
manager of in vivo research and
development at horizon discovery I am
Aaron Mayer gross also of horizon
discovery and I'll be your moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by lab roots
and sponsored by horizon discovery
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like at any time during the
presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and click on the send button
we'll save several questions for Andrew
and Kevin to answer during the Q&A
session additionally we have scientists
standing by to answer questions as they
come in during the presentation we will
answer as many questions as we can
if there are questions that we don't get
to we'll send an email response in the
coming days
additionally when this presentation is
available for on-demand viewing
questions can still be submitted and
will be routed to Andrew or Kevin and
the research team for an email response
also please notice that you will be
viewing the presentation in the slide
window to enlarge the window click on
the - arrow symbol at the top right hand
corner of the slide if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem through the ask a
question box
continuing educational credits are
offered for attending this webinar
please click on the continuing education
credits tab at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits also
check out the other tabs that contain
helpful resources that may answer
questions that will come up during this
webinar I would now like to introduce
our presenters Andrew Brown who will
briefly introduce the horizon product
portfolio and Kevin Forbes presenting
some exciting research
Andrew Brown is a product manager for
the invivo group at horizon discovery he
is a scientist with over 17 years
experience in both an academic and
biotechnology setting andrew began his
scientific career working as a scientist
in a mouse genetics core at Washington
University in st. Louis there he
developed a strong background in animal
model generation and characterization
after receiving a master's degree in
biology from Washington University in
st. Louis Andrew then moved into an
industry setting working as a research
scientist for Monsanto Company in a
molecular characterization lab driving
key projects through the company
pipeline fueled by a true passion for
human disease research
Andrew returned to research with
sigma-aldrich company working as a
scientist under Sage Labs where he
became part of horizon discovery in 2014
following a Masters in Business
Administration Andrew moved into his
current role with horizon as the product
manager of the invivo portfolio being
with the group for over seven years
okay now to Kevin
dr. Kevin Forbes is the manager of nvivo
research and development of horizon
discovery kevin joined horizon discovery
in 2014 during the acquisition of sage
labs
during his time in the invivo group in
st. Louis Missouri he worked on
developing and implementing gene editing
technologies focusing on CRISPR cash 9
and zinc finger nucleases for animal
model generation his primary focus has
been rat aadmi tox models for drug
development specifically nuclear
receptor and p450 gene knockouts and
humanized map rat models prior to Sage
Labs Kevin was the R&D lead for micro
RNA product development at sigma-aldrich
before that kevin was a USDA
postdoctoral fellow at the University of
South Carolina he received his PhD from
the University of Kentucky and plant
physiology now let's get started
Andrew I will hand the reins over to you
first
all right thank you very for that great
introduction
so I'd first like to personally welcome
everyone to our exciting presentation on
drug metabolism involving two of our 80
plus animal models including the two
models P X R and C AR so again my name
is andrew brown product manager of den
vivo group before we get into the
wonderful world of drug metabolism we
would like to take this opportunity this
great opportunity to give you a very
brief overview and I promise to be brief
of the entire horizon portfolio so
honestly today we'll be discussing our
animal models and how they apply to drug
metabolism which did as a product within
the invivo portfolio but however horizon
has a whole and a very large and
extensive offering of both products and
services outside of our invivo offering
this schematic is a good representation
of horizons offering as a whole at the
core of the business is genetic
engineering and gene modulation with
over ten years experience with multiple
genetic engineering technologies with
the latest and greatest being CRISPR
with that core capability we were able
to build on that core offering and offer
numerous solutions to our customers in
different scientific areas we offer
custom cell line engineering services
and also catalog
cell lines that are already established
our products and services and bio
production utilizing cho cells our
functional genomic screening platform
utilizing CRISPR and our recently
launched CRISPR aa4 activation and
CRISPR I our I for inhibition along with
CRISPR knockout in relation to that
platform we have our diagnostic services
and M products also our high-throughput
screening platform
with the recent acquisition of Dharma
Khan we were able to offer a broad range
of research reagents for the
do-it-yourself customer and then last
but not least is our in vivo portfolio
which you see at the bottom of that
schematic that we'll focus on today
if you break down our invivo offering
you can break it down into four
categories with our genetically
engineered model with our stage feed
custom where we utilize the technologies
of crisper and zfn to design and
generate a custom model for our
customers also our genetically engineer
engineer models that are already
established that we offer as our catalog
or off-the-shelf models these are
predominantly rap models that have
already been generated and are ready for
use they they involve different disease
areas such as neuroscience
cardiovascular and drug metabolism as
we'll talk about today our transport
transgenic support services which
predominantly make up of breeding we
were able to breed up your animal models
deliver cohorts and offer downstream
services such as crowd preservation and
tissue sampling to name a few and then
finally our patient-derived xenograft
models that we focus in breast cancer
and melanoma offerings that we do both
efficacy studies and have tumor cell
lines available for purchase and vials
so that's my pitch Thanks thank you for
making it through and listening so now
I'll turn it over Kevin so we can really
dive into drug metabolism
thank you for the nice introduction
Maren and Andrew again I'm Kevin Forbes
a manager of the invivo R&D group here
at horizon high horizon discovery I'd
like to share with you today some of the
models we've generated and are currently
characterizing that can be used in drug
development
I'll give you a brief history of our
nvivo group and some background into the
research area of the talk specifically
knockout and humanized aadmi talks rap
models
I'd like to start by giving you a little
bit of a history of the invivo group
here at Horizon discovery in 2007
sigma-aldrich partnered with Singham Oak
Biosciences now Sangamo therapeutics the
license their zinc finger nucleases
technology for product development
involved in research application sigma
parlayed that into launching
sigma-aldrich genetic engineering labs
staged labs in 2009 with the purpose of
applying the FNS the animal model
creation in 2013 sigma sold off the
invivo business to a venture capital
group and in 2014 we were acquired by
horizon discovery and as Andrew had
mentioned our focuses on custom knockout
and knockin model generation in mice
rats and rabbits
we also offer tumor and PDX services
around efficacy studies in the mouse and
we offer off-the-shelf catalog rat
models of disease and finally not listed
here in andreadd mentioned is we also
offer transgenic services that are
revolve around all of these areas
part of the off the shell offerings
include rat knockout lines as antibiotic
sensors like pxr car EHR PPAR alpha and
the subsequent double and triple
knockouts listed here below we also
offer a flocks and the uptake
transporter models
and these models are readily available
and can be found at the following links
or through our company's home webpage
so how do we generate knock out or knock
in models
so regardless of the nucleus technology
that you're using whether it be zinc
finger or towel domains flanking a
precise region within the genome each
one fused with the folk one enzyme to
generate a dimer or small guide RNAs to
direct cast nine to that same region the
CRISPR cast nine system you're
generating a nuclease induced
double-stranded break there are two
pathways utilized for a double-stranded
break repair non-homologous end joining
or homology directed repair for
non-homologous end joining besides
correct and precise rejoining the hope
is that you get a correct incorrect
repair that will create a mutation
within your target
examples are gene disruption directly
Gatien deletion inversion or a
translocation all targeted mutagenesis
you can also utilize the HDR pathway
where you can get repair off of a sister
chromatid or with the template donor to
incorporate a nucleotide modification or
insertion of a larger sequence at a
precise location within the genome
inserting the likes of trans genes and
their constitutive or tissue-specific
expression loxp sites for conditional
knockouts and/or gene tagging or
incorporating regulation sequences
so what are xenobiotic sensors they are
classified as nuclear receptors
transcription factors that bind foreign
or endogenous ligands prescription drugs
prescription drugs as a foreign example
then this binding causes a
conformational change in the receptor
and they bind to xenobiotic response
elements within promoter regions and
regulate the gene expression of phase
one enzymes the p450s phase two
conjugating and metabolism enzymes and
transporters
so in essence regulating drug
disposition genes by chemical activators
in this process of drug introduction
binding activation and metabolism is a
continual process you can have an impact
on how prescription drugs function
within the body
in addition environmental or hereditary
factors can have an impact on how these
receptors function and the genes that
they regulate
and finally since we are talking about
rodent models there is species
differences in terms of ligand binding
the human pxr as an example has a
preference for RIF and peson and the
rodent pxr PSN PCN as for car
differences in citko versus pcp VOP
binding but both have an affinity for
phenobarbital binding
of their differences in ligand binding
the regulation of these genes is quite
conserved across species
so a number of non genotoxic chemicals
have been shown to produce liver tumors
and rodents a good case study that's
continually being looked at within the
field is mode of action studies and
rodents for phenobarbital treatment
phenobarbital is best known as an
antiepileptic drug so wild-type mice
develop liver tumors after phenobarbital
treatment but mice that are knocked out
for the car gene do not and humanize
mice for the car gene in the knockout
background after FINA phenobarbital
treatment also do not develop liver
tumors so suggest that the liver tumor
formation is associated with the
induction of mouse antibiotic
metabolizing enzymes and it's mass with
mouse specific no human relevance if you
look further into the literature it also
suggests that phenobarbital treatment
produces liver tumors more readily in
the mouse and in the rat hence it's
necessary to have both mouse and rat
models available for rodent liver mode
of action studies
hopefully this gives you some insight
into how models like like this
especially ones focused around the
nuclear receptors are utilized in
toxicology studies
so we set out to generate rats knocked
out for the PX Arrancar receptors in
both cases we targeted exon 2 of each
gene with zinc finger nucleases the zfn
target site is the above line sequence
and they below and below is the deletion
sequence for PF SAR we identified a
founder with a 20 base pair deletion and
per car 10 base pair deletion we bred
these models to homozygosity and then
isolated RNA from extracted livers and
generated cDNAs for each gene
all the cdna is present in the
corresponding knockout animal contained
the deletion sequence which would encode
for a severely truncated protein lacking
the ligand and DNA binding domains of
each receptor this suggests we would
lose receptor function in those
corresponding knockout lines when
compared to rat to wild-type rats
weight changes the first indication that
the function of these genes was in fact
altered in the knockout animals we also
bred the car and pxr knockout lines to
generate the double knockout 4pxr in car
the plots are listed accordingly from
top to bottom pxr knockout wild-type
double knockout and then car knockout
from the time frame of 10 to 15 weeks
for males and 8 to 15 weeks for female
rats in both genders disruption of pxr
led to weight gain alone male rats the
increase was not statistically
significant in addition the male double
knockout rats were significantly lighter
than wild-type whereas feeble female
double knockout riots were comparable to
wired wild-type counterparts there are
involved the overall trend in rats is
that the disruption of pxr in car had an
opposite effect on weight and this
suggests that these nuclear receptors
function on regulating basal expression
levels of opposing sets of genes
contributing to body mass and their
effect cancelled each other out in the
female rat
so what about further functional
analysis here's our workflow for our
functional characterization of the
single knock out lines and again the
double pxr car knock out line we've read
we start with 10-week old males three
biological replicates and treat with
corn oil our vehicle PCN and known pxr
agnes or tcp o bo p unknown car Agnes
we euthanize the rats after a set amount
of time of treatment collect the same
region of the liver
homogenized the tissue and tri-zone and
then proceed to extract and purify total
liver total liver RNA then we generated
first strand cDNAs to be used in cyber
arrays or tak main queue PCR assays run
those reactions on our real time machine
and generate output data above here for
cyber and below for tac man assays and
then finally analyze the data
our cyber arrays and tapman assays are
designed to screen for several nuclear
receptor genes p450 phase two genes and
transporters
listed above our cyber array is a
collection of 48 genes so we can duplex
it with within a 96-well format with
built-in controls and five housekeeping
genes that we can calculate out average
relative drean expression levels
pac-man assays listed below cover other
phase 2 and transporter genes not
included in our cyber array and the
three housekeeping genes used for
relative gene expression calculation
so the hope with the output data is that
we observed changes in the threat the
threshold detection the CT values of the
gene of interest whether it be from the
knockout itself or from chemical
treatment when compared back to the Dex
detection level the housekeeping gene in
terms of relative expression levels
so here are a couple of samples of the
genes we analyzed from the Q PCR assays
we found that px Arrancar regulate
endogenous and drug-induced p450 gene
expression the left cluster of each
graph is vehicle treated animals the
middle cluster PCN treated and the right
cluster tcpo VOP treated
all normalized back to wild-type vehicle
treated rats the dashed line that you
see represents the value of one for
wild-type vehicle alone and we were
looking for values greater than two for
either up or down regulation of the gene
of interest
when we looked at just the vehicle
treated or ass for step 3 a1 and set to
be two there were elevated levels of
each gene and rats that lacked the pxr
gene represented by the red arrows and
force it to be to the levels were
reduced tenfold in the car knock out the
blue arrows
so if we look at PCN treated compared to
wild-type
in three a one for example when we
compare wild-type PCM to vehicle the
purple arrows
there's an induction of sip 3a1 gene
expression however when we do the same
comparison with pxr knock out the red
arrows there's no longer an observed
abduction induction of set 3 a1 by PCN
when we look at sit to be to for tcpo
VOP treatment again comparing treated to
vehicle there's an observed induction of
2v2 and wild-type the purple arrows but
no induction observed in the car
knockouts the red arrows
looking even further into the data force
it 3 a 1 in terms of PCN treatment in
the car knockout
we observed activation as with wild-type
since the pxr receptor is still present
and the same goes for sit to be 2 with
pxr knockout since the car gene is
present in those animals as well
here's an example of a couple phase two
genes and a transporter gene ug to be
one follows a similar pattern as
observed with sip to be to being
upregulated in pxr knockouts and
downregulated in car knockouts at the
endogenous level however no change in
expression level regardless of drug
treatment compared to vehicle
for another phase two enzyme salt to a
two and a transporter slc oh one A two
there's no change in endogenous levels
however there is a loss of PCN induction
in rats lacking the pxr gene again
comparing wild-type treated to vehicle
the red arrows and pxr knockout treated
the vehicle the purple arrows so Ness is
what we have here is the loss of
receptor function in the knockouts
here's a summary of the data in the
absence of a functional pxr gene these
genes are upregulated in the absence of
car a minor three a four family member
the p450 set 389 is upregulated and set
to be two and ug to be one are down
regulated
as well the PCN induction of the
following genes are tied to pxr gene
function and 2 3 8 9 2 car function the
only TCP OBO P induction of set to be 2
is related to the car gene function and
all this data is in good agreement with
published data from human primary patta
sites knockout cell lines and knockout
mouse models
in addition just recently another group
of concept life sciences which is
formerly cxr Biosciences they published
on the single car in PSR knockout lines
with data in line with our observations
here with treatments of sodium
phenobarbital and PCN
in addition to having invivo ratlines
4pxr car and the double knockout we've
partnered with in vitro advent labs ivo
for the isolation and cryopreservation
of a pata cites from those models
available hepatocyte lines are listed to
the right
including a few transporter lines that
we have here if you're not equipped to
house rats these isolated the pata sites
can be used for in vitro screening
purposes
as you can see the hepatocytes come out
of cryo very nicely and culture are
viable and have drug metabolizing enzyme
activity obey it different from
wild-type what you would expect from a
pata sites that are knocked out for
these nuclear drug receptors
so we played it and screen those two
pata sites with TC n and TCP OB o P and
found that they are functionally
equivalent to the in vivo models similar
loss of gene induction with those
corresponding compounds as an example
here we look at 381 comparing treated to
vehicle treated within each knockout
line compared to wild-type and we
observed induction of sip 3 a one gene
expression from both compounds and the
loss of that induction within the
corresponding knockout line
we didn't observe induction of three a
one by TC POV Opie within the in vivo
studies also also with observed loss of
the induction in the car knockout lines
this difference observed here between
isolated of parasites in in vivo may be
due to several different metabolism
factors if you will
including delivery and availability of
the compound to to be absorbed
transported to the liver cells for
metabolism
that difference the knock out pata sites
show lots of receptor function in terms
of gene regulation of the drug
metabolism pathway and are valuable and
betray alternative to the in vivo models
so those knockout models fit right into
the humanized model we have generated a
rat knocked out for the sit three eight
family members pxr car as we've
mentioned and another receptor HR
then we humanize the rat by a back
transgenesis which is random integration
of the human gene for the corresponding
human genes it is also imperative that
these genes expressed both in the liver
and the gut so with this model we will
have you know loss of the rat function
of these genes and complemented them
with their human counterpart this will
allow for a human specific study within
an in vivo animal model the advantage
the rat has over mice for this
particular model it's a larger size in
essence you could be more frequent blood
draws easier surgical or surgical
procedures like can you lations for
continued drug delivery and they're you
know they're better maze runners meaning
better neurological models of study
so I mentioned we made a knock out for
the a charging so here's our HR knockout
model again here using zfn the target
exon2 and we identified a founder rat
with a 760 base pair deletion that spans
intron 1 and X onto these rats have loss
of HR gene expression and when treated
with a known HR Agnes TC DDT TCDD we
observed loss of TCDD induction of sip 1
a one sip 1 a 2 in the transporter ABC C
3 which is MRP 3 when comparing the
knockout to wild-type rats
in addition I've seen with other nuclear
receptors pxr in car we observed reduce
endogenous gene expression level levels
of a p450 gene set 3 1 a to the middle
graph here in the HR knockout
so the other knockout lineman we
mentioned it was generating a knockout
line for the SIP 3a4 family in rat which
consists of two copies of set 3 a 1 3 a
18 3 a 9 and 3 a 2 we code micro
injected into rat embryos small guide
RNAs that targets the 3a genes and
identified four founders out of 30 live
burst with deletions at all targets and
both alleles one of those founders
contained deletions that all the alleles
that are predicted to generate missense
mRNAs we back cross that founder to
wild-type and bred to homozygous
knockout colony we isolated liver RNA
from those knockouts screened by a qPCR
and it seemed that the button at the
bottom left here the grafts we were able
to determine that we had loss of gene
expression for the rat 3a for gene
family when compared to wild-type on the
right of each graph though so we saw a
reduction of each of expression of each
3a for family member in the knockout
line
so for our humanized lines the back
lines we wanted to determine where they
integrated so we determined by fish and
sky analysis where in the the genome the
human genes that integrated and how many
integration sites there were so using
fish analysis in the above panels with
metaphase chromosome spread generated
from rat blood cells either looking at
wild-type or the the back humanized
lines we probed with a back gene
specific green labelled probe and an X
chromosome paint probe in red
as you can see in this example we have
one integration site one brief dot one
green dot for a head rat and two for a
home and in the panel below this back
could be located in a particular
chromosomal arm within the rat
chromosome 15 using fish and sky
analysis
all of our back lines follow this
pattern of one detected integration site
and with the help of Julie komen at the
Van Andel Institute was it using fish
and sky we were able to determine their
genomic location
so here's the rat chromosomal map with
the location of the endogenous rat genes
we've knocked out in the blue boxes and
the red bars representing where within
the genome the human genes have
integrated in this aids in breeding of
the traits within the humanized model to
homozygosity
so for humanized backlines we have
extracted RNA from livers and small
intestine ran qPCR assays to determine
that the human genes were expressed and
as an example here we did detect the
expression of the human genes and those
tissues currently we are underway
testing human specific compounds like
citko for car revamped assembler pxr
omeprazole for HR in grapefruit extract
for set 3a for inhibition this is what
we are testing in the complete humanized
model right now with all the human genes
and the rat genes knocked out
so in review pxr ankara nuclear
receptors regulate endogenous and
induced drug metabolism and transporter
genes these knockout models are useful
for studying metabolism of xenobiotic
compounds of pata toxicity and
complement existing cell and mouse
models and for the humanized rat we'll
know soon their function in studying the
metabolism as antibiotic compounds and a
pata toxicity
so with that I'd like to recognize the
members of the Rd and office group
members that animal facility who provide
animal care and treatments for the
animals
our partners at I eval for Pat aside
isolation Tom Sanders who has aided us
in terms of back transgenesis and Julie
Coleman at the Van Van Andel Institute
and sellon genetics for our fish and sky
analysis I thank you for your time and
will entertain any questions you may
have thank you
you
thank you Andrew and Kevin for the
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar now while we are getting ready
for the Q&A session two polling
questions will appear on your screen we
really appreciate your answers to these
questions so that we can follow up
appropriately with you
I would like to remind our audience so
you can submit questions by typing them
into the ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen just type
your question into the box and hit Send
will answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay Kevin and Andrew
you're close unmuted and back on the
line that correct yes yes all right all
right
the first question in the queue here is
how many compounds have you tested for
your pxr and card knockout line
I assume that one's for me yeah Evan
yeah so far right sorry Kevin so far
we've just tested internally P CNN tcpo
Bo P for both models but that recent
publication by concept Life Sciences
added you know treatment of sodium
sodium being a part at all to that list
as well so so far it's been three
compounds all right excellent okay let's
see the next question I have here oh
this one's clear dear dr. Forbes have
you thought of doing RNA seek on your
knockout lines compared to wild-type
wouldn't that give a more complete
picture of the gene regulation role of
those receptors with or without
treatment
yes we have that's a very good question
that would be extremely valuable data in
terms of looking at global gene
expression in addition to Zenta biotic
function so that's you know the PX
Arrancar receptors have been linked to
other endogenous metabolism pathways
obesity you name it there's been a
really strongly through those receptors
so the current plan is to compare
wild-type the individual knockouts and
the humanized lines and look at the
differences and the complementation by
those human genes so that is in the
queue and something that we are looking
at doing excellent thanks Kevin and -
another question for you from one of our
viewers do you have a hypothesis for the
difference between the weight of the
male and female double knockout rats
so as you know the data suggests that
these nuclear receptors function on
regulating basal expression levels of
opposing sets of genes contributing to
body mass and you know their effect
canceled each other out in yunnan in the
female merits you know similar
observations on gender differences have
been made in mice in terms of gene
regulation of metabolism genes and it it
very well could be tight so far more
hormonal changes since the differences
are observed once these animals have
reached sexual maturity it also raising
you know the questions of whether is
sufficient to use only male animals or
pharmacal pharmacological tests as the
standard method currently used
interesting okay to the next question
coming through this one looks like it's
for Andrew how readily available are
your knockout lines
so our rat models are maintained as a
demand based model with that meaning as
more orders come in we scale-up breeder
pairs to try to reduce waste as you will
see on our website the models are listed
with one of four statuses those four
statuses are readily available which
generally means we can deliver animals
within a two to three week time frame
secondly is available which means we can
generally deliver those within a four to
six week time frame limited availability
six to ten weeks and then also
cryopreserved so preferred age of
delivery is also a factor on how
available the animals are these statuses
are constantly changing so it's best to
inquire through our website or through
your local sales representative so we
can get you an estimated timeline for
delivery
thank you Andrew oh and it looks like
the next question is for you as well of
course how much does it cost for each
not animal yeah great question and the
ultimate question so generally these
these models can range from either $200
up to $500 per animal it is really
dependent on two factors the age of the
animal that you would like delivered and
also the customer type with our academic
customers receiving significant
discounts on the models our prices on
our website are currently listed at
commercial prices for industry customers
so for academic prices is best to
inquire which you can also do through
the website or your local sales
representative excellent all right it
looks like the next question is is back
to Kevin how long can you culture and
treat the cryopreserved hepatocytes
so far we've cultured and treated them
up to seven days with the adaptation of
newer culturing methods coming out
almost daily in the field the hope is
that they extend them out at least
twenty-one days maybe more but right now
we've only done the testing up to seven
days
great great thanks Kevin okay the next
question I'm seeing here let's say yeah
this one is probably for Kevin again how
will you know your humanised lines are
truly humanized and not from potential
secondary effects from remaining rat
genes the best option we have is by
rodent in human specific compound
treatment you know of the wild type
knockout lines and the humanized model
you know then look at gene expression
and metabolite profiles to determine
true humanized gene function and not the
rat mechanism of action
all right great oh okay so it looks like
we are approaching the end of our time
slot and we can address one last
questions this one appears to be for
Andrew how long is the time frame if I
want a custom knock out or knock in rat
involved in aadmi talks I don't see it
in your catalog sure that's great
question if you uh browse through our
catalog and we don't have a specific
gene knockout or gene knock in model and
then in the catalog we'd love to provide
that as a custom model through our stage
speed custom model services so the time
frame from purchase order to delivery of
f1 breeder pair or breeder pairs at six
weeks of age can be as little as five
months
keeping in mind that's delivery of f1
breeder pairs so the founders will
actually be generated much sooner we
generate those typically around two to
three months the timelines for those can
vary based on project complexity
depending on if it's a simple knockout
or a more complex knock in so it's best
to request a quote and we'll get you a
quote with a detailed statement
statement of work of everything that we
would do through the generation process
it also will outline the process and
timeline again best way to to get that
as submit through our website horizon
discovery calm or if you're already
familiar with your local sales
representative to work with them
directly
great great again thank you to the
audience for all of the wonderful
questions and to Kevin and Andrew for
your answers I see that there are a few
more questions remaining in the queue
and if your question was not answered
one of our scientists will respond to
you via email if you have further
questions that you did not submit during
this broadcast please email them to info
at Horizon discovery.com
all right before we go we would like to
thank lab roots and horizon discovery
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand
through November 2018 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
to relay on demand we encourage you to
share the email with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event and
in a second you'll see an exit poll come
up on your screen we appreciate your
feedback as it will help us plan for
future webinars we would love for you to
join us for our next scheduled webinar
on June 27th focusing on tips and tricks
for crisper cast 9 so 9 engineering
until next time goodbye